des salles ouvertes évident comme
abandonnés des couloirs ou ne raisonnent
tôt qu'un pas nous sommes à orléans en
avril dernier pendant le troisième
confinement un campus désert nous avons
suivi laurine mario mégane dans leur
quotidien trois étudiants ou parcours
bouleversé par le cos vide entre
solitude et décrochage
à 18 ans laurine est entrée à
l'université d'orléans en septembre elle
a eu deux mois de cours sur le campus
et puis rapidement le deuxième
confinement a imposé les cours à
distance
j'ai à peine eu le temps de m'adapter en
présentiel pendant deux mois j'ai j'y
suis allé puis d'un seul coup on est
passé en l'hybride
j'ai pas j'ai eu la chance d'être en
présentiel une semaine avant le
confinement après les cours ça a été
compliqué j'ai terminé mon premier
semestre en distance yale et j'avais un
minimum de motivation au tout début du
deuxième semestre mais là ça venait
vraiment pesant ces tests est long ce
matin laurine passe en examen d'anglais
à distance un peu résigné c'est pas
vraiment les uns c'est je rédige ses je
rédige quelque chose que je peux rédigé
en classe et la seule différence c'est
que cette fois c'est noté
mario et étudiants erasmus
il poursuit son master en france après
avoir vécu le premier confinement en
italie je le savais déjà un peu qui il
est déjà en grosse encourt le risque
d'un nouvel confinement et mais je
l'avais accepter aussi parce que après
le premier compliment que j'ai passé en
italie
j'ai pitié je ne peux pas la ceao confie
mario gobbi de fermer d'arrêter ma vie
donc je vais aller en france
j'ai déjà gêné dans la plus belle six
mois de ma vie je ne veux pas j'étais en
notre âme et mario a choisi de prendre
une chambre en cité universitaire sur le
campus pour éviter la solitude d'un
appartement en ville et profiter de la
cuisine commune
le fait d'avoir trouvé à un autre petite
famille ici c'est à changer tout a
changé tout la situation
je ne peux pas imaginer en confinement
sens mes amis ici parce que en italie ou
en italie on dit que en douleur partagée
c'est en 2010 leur
8 heures du matin
megan est apprenti en licence pro à
l'iut de bourges
elle se rend dans son entreprise à
châteauroux à 21 ans elle est chef de
chantier à la colas prendre un trop gros
je pense que tout le temps pas la
chargeuse on y va la brouette et megan
est arrivé de nouvelle calédonie pour
continuer ses études sur l'hexagone
le virus a freiné ses ambitions elle n'a
pas pu trouver un employeur qui veulent
s'engager pour trois ans avait été
accepté dans une école d'ingénieurs sur
trois ans en apprentissage donc ça j'ai
pas pu j'ai pas pu signer ce contrat là
et à la plage y signer un contrat d'un
an licence pro et donc ça ça a été
assez compliqué c'est toujours compliqué
aujourd'hui parce que là après la
licence j'aimerai toujours poursuivre
jusqu'en master jai trouvé une école de
conduite de travaux dans laquelle j'ai
été accepté et j'attends toujours la
réponse de mon entreprise
donc en fait c'est le co vide qui les
bloque au niveau du nombre d'apprentis
qui peuvent accepter etc
et j'attends toujours des réponses même
si l'activité a repris très rapidement
après le premier confinement dans le
secteur du btp
l'avenir est encore incertain pour les
employeurs et les alternants doivent
patienter
là on a une problématique cette année
c'est à dire que là on arrive sur un
renouvellement de contrat donc mais en a
plein qui qui arrive en termes de leur
contrat donc soit ils me demandent une
poursuite d'études
soit ils souhaitent se réorienter sur
d'autres secteurs d'activité même dans
notre dans nos métiers il ya un manque
de projet est ce qu'on appelle les
projets fil rouge les aménagement du
centre-bourg etc qui sont arrêtés du
fait des élections du fait du coc vite
qui consomme une partie des finances des
collectivités et on sait qu'on a des
besoins mais quelque part on est aussi
prudent sur notre activité et tous nos
alternant sont pas tous les jours dans
mon bureau mais ils me lancent
régulièrement pour savoir et surtout
définir le nombre d'alternants convard
combien
[Musique]
pour notre étudiante en première année
de lettres et langues c'est un grand
jour laurine se rend à la fac pour
passer un examen en présentiel
ça fait du bien parce que rester enfermé
encore et encore et encore c'est ça
devient long
au moins je vais voir avoir un peu de
contacts humains un examen de
linguistique anglaise que laurine passe
seul face à son professeur ravi aussi de
retrouver une salle de cours je vous
donne le sujet moi je suis enseignante
pour justement avoir des étudiants pour
être debout pour être au tableau est
donc là déjà c'est comme si on avait un
petit peu coupé les jambes parce qu on
est assis il a fallu jongler avec les
étudiants en présentiel qui était
content de revenir
sachant que vous n'avez pas énormément
de toute façon mais en plus il fallait
jongler avec les étudiants qui étaient à
distance
on sait qu'ils les profs sont quand même
là pour nous il nous le répète ils nous
disent qu'il faut surtout pas hésiter à
envoyer des mails envoyés des messages
sur steam sur celle n importe où mais ça
reste pas le contact élèves profs auquel
on a été habitué et ben c'est pas
forcément facile tout le temps
professeurs ou élèves
les habitudes ont été bouleversés depuis
le début de la pandémie et pour certains
cela s'est traduit par un mal être
général entre arrêts maladie et des
motivations dans les premières années
malheureusement cette année il y a eu
énormément de ce qu'on appelle du
décrochage d'hier des étudiants qui ont
baissé les bras qui n'ont même pas passé
les épreuves du premier semestre à peu
près 1 sur 2 et c'est beaucoup plus que
d'habitude alors je pense que dans ce
découragement de ses étudiants de
première année
cette année il ya le fait que c'est des
étudiants qui ne connaissait pas du tout
l'enseignement supérieur et qui n'ont
pas passé le bac je le rappelle ils ont
été déjà ils ont eu une année de
terminale très compliqué et ils ont eu
un mois et demi de cours et la pressent
les a renvoyés chez eux
[Musique]
c'est l'heure du déjeuner le campus
s'anime
depuis janvier le crous a décidé de
proposer deux repas à 1 euro pour les
étudiants boursiers ou non et pour mario
c'est une bonne nouvelle
[Applaudissements]
mario juge avec 300 euros de bourse et
quelques économies personnelles
donc tout est bon à prendre pour gérer
au mieux son budget si leur est pas à
l'euro c'est pas grand différence entre
anne euros et 3 euros
mais c'est le geste que te fait dire par
fait je suis passé j'ai en bourse
et heureusement aussi ma universités m'a
donné de l'argent avec la bourse et donc
c'est s'était pas impossible de vivre
ici sans être un poids pour ma famille
s'aérer rencontrer des amis faire une
pause déjeuner tout pour s'extraire des
écrans et penser à autre chose que sa
condition d'étudiants confiné dîner tout
seul et après aller à dormir tout seul
ces lourdes ses lourdes parce que là la
soirée c'est le moment où tout laisse
penser son cloud plus lourdes mais ici
la possibilité de dîner avec des amis
d'hier des blagues dire des choses et
après aller dormir trouvait à dormir
avec ta tête qui est plus légère et le
jour après tout commence sa journée et
tout ça
en fin de chantier pour notre apprenti
il est 17 heures elle rentre chez elle
sa 2e journée commence c'est l'occasion
de travailler sur son projet de fin
d'année c'est vrai que cette année
c'était un peu compliqué présidentielle
en général j'arrive toujours à gérer et
à prendre de l avance sur mes devoirs
mais là je pense qu'il ya une
démotivation des courants distance et
que l' avance clairement cette année
tout le monde a eu un peu la flemme pour
megan le premier confinement a été
difficile mais elle a su s'en sortir
toujours avec le sourire avec le premier
groupe nord est du coup ça a été
compliqué parce que je me suis séparée
dont
mme ex-petite amie avec qui j'étais
depuis six ans donc penser la fin d'une
relation donc c'est toujours compliqué
en plus quand c'est qu'au vide et puis
qu'on peut pas forcément avoir des
logements comme ça c'est j'ai dormi un
petit peu dans ma voiture et j'ai été
logés après par des collègues
donc heureusement qu'ils étaient là et
sinon ouais il vaut de la solitude ça
fait trois ans que c'est compliqué des
pitchs en france en fait de surtout dans
des moments comme ça en fait ne pas
pouvoir se dire je vais rentrer chez ma
mère et puis et puis reste un peu
minable là c'est vraiment dur avec
regarde en fait t'as vu ça c'est un look
et de sécurité depuis elle a trouvé une
chambre chez l'habitant
sarah la loge quand megan à ces
chantiers à châteauroux le soir elle
retrouve parfois ses amis un moment
indispensable pour lutter contre la
solitude c'est en fait une façon de se
sentir épaulé et d'avoir une stabilité
surtout quand tu vas voir le moment de
familles aidées loin du coup donc là je
sais que sandra sandra quand j'étais
malade elle est partie c'est grand frais
m'acheter des petites prix exprès coco
passion parce qu'elle sait que j'adore
ça extrait pour me booster et puis quand
jd d'épaves de voitures qu'en dit ça m'a
emmené pour dépanner pour pouvoir aller
à bourges en cours hugo mes galères de
voitures avis qu'ils aient des cammazes
soutient aussi et puis bah c'est cool de
pouvoir inviter mon chéri de savoir que
la maison à l'ouverte sandra aller est
assez cool de suite non c'est assez
sympathique
[Musique]
en fin de journée aussi pour mario
enfermé dans sa chambre
ils doivent passer un examen de français
à l'oral en visio et sur son téléphone
portable
centre aquatique de préjugés choisi un
travail que tu aimes et tous ne devra
pas travailler en ce jour d'établir
lisez confucius mes professeurs
il espère aussi pouvoir poursuivre ses
études en france
l'université a ouvert ses portes aux
étudiants qui le souhaitaient malgré le
confinement à 6,1 et à l'est par exemple
mes amis ils ne sont jamais allés au aux
cours en présentiel
après la le début que vides
ici j'ai eu beaucoup d'occasions d'aller
en présentiel
donc je comprendre que pour l'état à
ouvrir les universités c'est un sujet
qui est centrale donc pour cette raison
mais aussi un jeu j'aime j'ai un peu de
confiance pour les futures
mario doit retourner en italie à la fin
de ce semestre
il ne sait pas pour l'instant s'il
pourra revenir en france
laurine retrouve des amis de lycée à
quelques rues de sa résidence
la première sortie ses camarades de
promo elle n'a pu les croiser que sur
les discussions en ligne
là où l'insouciance et les soirées
étudiantes rituels et semaines de cours
les premières années ont connu
uniquement la situation présente du
confinement
ça devient de pire en pire le fait de
pas avoir de vie sociale en fait c'est
la seule vie sociale que j'ai cessé sur
des réseaux comme discorde sur what's
app c'est pas pareil c'est clairement
pas pareil tout le monde aimerait en
fait se retrouver il n'y a pas une
semaine où on se dit pas ben en fait on
aimerait bien se revoir enfin on
aimerait bien se voir tout simplement et
s'amuser mais en vrai laurine prend son
mal en patience
comme tous ses camarades en attendant
des jours meilleurs bah être étudiant de
2021 c'est devoir accepter le fait
d'être enfermé pour certains d'être
complètement seuls isolés de leurs
familles dans neuf mètres carrés être
étudiant de niveau interne mais c'est
juste tout simplement compliqué c'est et
c'est démotivant l'année universitaire
se termine une année à s'adapter et à se
contraindre à une vie à distance pour
nos étudiants retrouver les salles de
cours les professeurs et les discussions
entre amis semblent primordiales en
espérant un retour sur le campus à la
rentrée prochaine